Riverdale delivers a sexy updated take
on the classic Archie comics but what
would it look like if the cast was a
little closer to the comics counterparts
Jughead Jones to take on an angsty
version of Jughead Cole Sprouse died his
naturally blonde hair - dark brown and
sports the character's signature hat no
matter how weird it might be the only
thing that keeps him from being a dead
ringer is jugheads Pinocchio style knows
Archie Andrews like Kevin keller said in
episode 1 Archie got hot KJ APA's Archie
is super jacked with red dyed hair
alongside thick black eyebrows of the
comics he makes viewers believe that
Archie Andrews could be the kind of guy
two best friends would fight over for 80
years but he's still missing the
trademark freckles and clumsiness of the
comics Betty Cooper Riverdale's resident
brilliant blonde is played by Lilly
Reinhardt who sports Betty's iconic
ponytail when she's not sporting a wig
as dark Betty
Reinhardt's hair is a little darker than
the cartoon blonde of comics and she
lacks the bangs that Betty is usually
depicted with other than that though she
could have stepped off the page Veronica
Lodge Brazilian American actress Camilla
Mendez said she wasn't planning on
auditioning for Veronica until she found
out the producers were making the
character latina and as she liked that
the character wasn't a stereotype aside
from the change in background in the
Bettie Page bang set Veronica has in the
comics Mendes is virtually identical to
Riverdale's richest teenager Sheryl
blossom Sheryl blossom was once banned
from Archie comics for being too sexy
but Madeleine pitched steals the show as
the river vixens dramatic HBIC whether
she's involved in a murder mystery or
shooting enemies with arrows like cheryl
of the comics Pech is red-headed
although her hair's darker than in the
comics and her brown eyes depart from
Cheryl's green Kevin Keller Kevan Keller
made headlines in 2010 when he was
introduced as the first openly gay
character in Archie comics and has been
a mainstay of the cast ever since actor
Casey Cox hair is dark brown along with
green eyes those are both departures
from comic book Kevin Keller who sports
wavy blond hair and bright blue eyes
miss Grundy the character we think is
geraldine Grundy isn't Jennifer Gibson's
stole Grundy's identity and started an
free relationship with fifteen-year-old
Archie thirty-four-year-old Sara hable
is pretty different from comics Grundy
in every way we eventually see the real
miss Grundy in the newspaper looking
exactly like a comics counterpart but
otherwise we're far from the source here
Fred Andrews on TV former teen
heartthrob Luke Perry sports a full head
of hair and chiseled good looks showing
exactly where his son Archie gets his
handsomeness that's a stark contrast to
comic book Fred Andrews who's overweight
and nearly bald and that's a good thing
too the bald mustachioed look Perry is
not the Luke Perry we want Hiram Lodge
as Hiram Lodge Mark Consuelos has a
sinister cool the physique to grapple on
the wrestling mat and the edge to
intimidate mobsters like papa poutine
but cool and sinister aren't words that
could plausibly describe him in the
comics with white hair a thick moustache
and glasses
Hiram's a stuffy businessman who tends
to fall into swimming pools tawny topaz
tawny Tobi's was introduced into the
comics as the potential love interest
for Jughead which meant she was a
competitive eater who crushed the
competition at a cupcake eating contest
on the show Vanessa Morgan's ability to
scarf down dessert says he had to be
fully explored but beyond that she bears
a pretty strong resemblance to her
comics counterpart penny Peabody penny
Peabody is definitely the most obscure
character to make it to the screen
originally appearing as a child in the
little Archie spin-off Britt Morgan
brings her to TV as a ruthless attorney
working for the Southside serpents and
given what happens between her and
Jughead it's probably for the best that
Riverdale made her a much older woman
Nick st. Claire unlike most characters
on Riverdale Nick st. Clair wasn't
originally designed for the cartoony
style that we all recognize from Archie
comics instead he was introduced as a
modern bad boy Graham Phillips lacks the
spiky hair and soul patch from the
comics but otherwise he absolutely plays
Nick with the same smug Smarr meanness
that makes him so hateable the red
circle in the comics red circle is a
line of superhero comics featuring
characters like the shield Jaguar and
fly girl
Riverdale transformed that idea by
having Archie get inspired to form a
vigilante gang of masked shirtless teens
after reading too many funny books the
only thing that would have made it
weirder is a
Archy actually started fighting crime as
the shield
[Music]